power that'll last forever or like you
know decently long time and look if
you're a billionaire and you've got 10
million liquid just sitting around
mm-hmm
shrug all right bill didn't you walk
away we don't think twice and then you
know I bet Elon Musk has got one like
you know everybody got a crazy I bet
he's got a spaceship I bet I wouldn't be
surprised if feelin musk had a small
personal spaceship to like you know
Superman off the planet before it blows
up
then what go to I don't know no you
probably yeah created the Iron Man suit
he's just gonna be like I mean it
doesn't even work that's the problem
like I think I always thought it was
funny like with Iron Man he's got like a
couple millimeters of steel up against
his face oh yeah and that's gonna stop
you from like if you get hit in the head
with a baseball bat while you're wearing
a helmet
like it might help for sure it will help
yeah but he gets clobbered yeah yeah
everything by like 50 Cal like that
wouldn't that would give you a
concussion but slammed against the wall
from like Thanos like all these fights I
just I used to imagine he's got special
technology in the suit I guess mm-hmm
like we you know you know that ivory
vibranium like dampeners or something
whoa well I don't know we got to read
about the silo thing but I do want to
point one thing out in the Marvel stuff
why it is that in his suit he can get
thrown on my fan house and bashed
repeatedly yet when war machine falls in
the suit oh yeah he becomes partially
paralyzed oh yeah I thought the suit
when there's no electricity in the suit
it doesn't protect him well I mean it
was it wasn't the real Iron Man suit
that was the leftover no this is in
civil war ease up yeah I know maybe
maybe Industries beefed it up didn't
they yeah maybe but maybe it's because
when it's powered it can absorb the
impact better well let's see what the
rich people up to you know I got
something to say about this because we
lived in when we lived in Miami we
actually lived like not too far from an
abandoned missile silo
yeah and that's actually where a lot of
the toxins that was in our water that we
found was coming from from they were
saying like
a lot of these like your the uranium
that was in her water that was from
farming was from the farm yeah yeah but
I was reading about it but the there was
a lot of like toxic toxicity in the
metals going down like Lakes these
stores wouldn't want to live in that
place why would you want to surround
yourself by in a place like that well I
don't know anything I think at this
point well yeah I know but I guess it's
got like what ten stories deep well
actually let's read it yeah let's see
what they say well regular people stock
up on water and canned goods amid
coronavirus worries members of the 1%
are preparing more expensive bag of lies
I got to stop you right there
the 1% cannot afford a missile silo
we're talking at the point zero one
percent yeah we're talking about
Zuckerberg and Bezos and musk
billionaires billionaires some dude who
lives in Manhattan who makes you know 3
or $50,000 a year cannot afford a
nuclear missile silo
they say imagine you are a millionaire
or billionaire anxious about a deadly
virus but around the globe ravaging
populations and offending trade
relations and financial markets what
would you do where would you and your
sex of treasure go to hide from
spiraling calamity under the current
circumstances this is not an idle
question for the world's wealthy and
some of them are bunkering down
literally enter survival condo a
15-story deep cold war-era missile silo
that has been repurposed as a luxury
condo complex the weapons that once
occupied the space were called Atlas
missiles the first missiles capable of
crossing continents to deliver an
Armageddon level nuclear warhead for a
few years after their deployment in 1959
1959 they were among the deadliest
objects on earth but by 1965 the Atlas
had become obsolete and the 72 missile
sites were decommissioned half the silos
were destroyed by the government the
remaining empty silos and land around
them were auctioned off farmers often
bought them for pennies on the dollar
and use the land for grazing Larry Hall
the developer and owner of survival
condos looked at these abandoned silos
and saw business opportunities these
were enormous underground cylindrical
bunkers with hardened concrete walls up
to nine feet thick and built to
withstand a direct nuclear strike whoa
a perfect place to hide out from the
kind of world ending disasters the Atlas
missiles might once have created in 2008
Hall worked with the state of Kansas to
find a silo that could be adapted for
residential living after acquiring one
such silo in 2010 Hall started the
arduous task of pumping out 1.3 million
gallons of accumulated rainwater and
gutting the silo of rusting launch
structures and debris with a silo
emptied Hall constructed a
state-of-the-art underground condo
building with a twist the occupants of
this luxury condo building with
redundant power systems military-grade
air filters and a five-year supply of
food and water could survive the
apocalypse for five years though yeah
and then you're basically entombed the
mission is to protect residents from a
whole wide range of threats ed Hall
everything from viral or bacterial
threats and chemicals to volcanic ash
meteor solar flares and civil unrest and
on pressure humans can find a bunker I
don't know we'll see what happens he's
got a surge of interest in his survival
condos as the rise of kovat 19 has made
people of all income bracket suddenly
condoms made them suddenly contemplate
their these those sort of disasters
ammunition sales are through the roof
some Asian Americans worried about
racist violence are buying guns hand
sanitizer is in short supply and people
are bulk buying toilet paper even if
they aren't sure why yes and we talked
about that at Great Lengths
stores that sell products like survival
rations have seen huge sales spikes my
Patriot supplies an online retailer of
emergency and survival gear is so
overwhelmed that its website warns
would-be Preppers about supply shortages
and long waits national demand for
storable food remains near 100 times
normal volume shipping will be delayed
and orders potentially eight weeks or
more in many cases complete checkout to
reserve your place in line now it reads
a pop-up on the site
full disclosure that's the company that
I was promo in is it I was thinking it
is yeah yeah so that's though that's
through a special site for my like it's
a an affiliate program kind of thing so
you know I absolutely promoted them I
think maybe like five or six times and
it's crazy because when I first decided
to shout them out
I started thinking first of all I was
late to the game a lot of people had
been doing it well in advance they were
like this might be it and for me I'm
like man I'm too milquetoast
but then finally I was like when I saw
the Senate confirmation thing well
nothing's another confirmation they was
Senate testimony where they were like
this gonna get bad
I said hey maybe it's a good idea to do
this three days later the volume was so
insanely high you know they were like
you're gonna wait nine weeks a nine
weeks is better than nothing that's a
good point yeah if it makes it yeah
Atlas survival shelter says after a
survival shelter which sells a wide
range of bunkers and shelters as well as
survival materials has also seen a huge
spike in the sale of their survival
goods especially food supplies are sold
out said ron Hubbard the president of
Atlas survival shelter there is nothing
to buy and no suppliers to refill
supplies Hubbard added that there has
also been an uptick in interest in their
survival shelters the cheapest of which
starts at thirty-five thousand nine
hundred ninety nine if non billionaires
are shelling out that much money for
backyard bunkers it stands to reason
that the wealthy are doing something
similar
survival counter units cost 1.5 million
dollars for nine hundred square feet or
4.5 million for 3600 square feet and
prices can go higher if you customize
the space for example one Saudi customer
opted to add an underground mosque as
well as it concealed some Turanian James
Bond style helicopter hangar he's linked
by a tunnel to their unit man that's
cool each unit is equipped with an
upscale modern kitchen and bathroom as
well as virtual windows wall screens
that show a video video relayed of the F
of the outside world the building also
features a gym a swimming pool and a
movie theater alongside waste processing
facilities a shooting ring a shooting
range a dog walking area a classroom and
aquaculture in the past Hall told Vice
sales have been relatively slow if you
could afford the price and not many of
the planets wealthy are so concerned
about the end of the world that they're
rushing to spend that much on a back-up
plan but in the era of kovat 19 that is
changing a new owner in early March went
from seeing a unit online to purchasing
it four days later sight unseen
Paul said sales have been so strong that
Hall has almost sold out his
in survival condo facility located
another undisclosed Atlas silo site in
Kansas at 150,000 square feet this
project will be even larger and can
house more people I got it I got a say
this story interesting yeah
the these supplies being drained very
interesting yeah I think most people
won't admit it but most people think
we're looking at the apocalypse maybe
not most people a lot of people do the
people that are rushing in and buying
all the toilet paper yeah maybe the
reason is they don't think they'll ever
be toilet paper again like what he's
saying about this bunker is interesting
that some guy just showed up without
even not sure - but like went online
without even looking at it said I'm
dropping millions of dollars in this
that says to me that if people are
buying all this stuff yeah they might
act calm and they should and say things
like you know I think we're gonna be
calm but I think deep down they're going
like oh man oh this is scary yeah it is
scary yeah dude it's scary I mean the
potential for wrecking the human
population is very high I don't think I
could live in a bunker like this man
look at this photo I mean it's cool like
it's really cool I'd like to visit it
it'd be fun to go there once or twice
but to live underground like that I
don't know I think I could do it I don't
think so
like fallout I play I play video games I
escaped into another world so like
that's how I would go still well I
should probably put it this way into the
world if I had to do it you could yeah I
could yeah I wouldn't want I think if
you could kind of keep yourself thinking
that you could just leave any time it
might be a little bit easier but if
you're like oh my gosh I have to be here
there's nowhere I can go you would end
up pacing around no matter how big it
was
yeah no matter how you think the
government has a bunch of these like and
fallout definitely I think they do yeah
there's like a nother one under the
White House like underground tunnels and
stuff yeah yeah yeah I'm pretty sure
yeah and then an x-men magneto pulls it
from the ground yeah yeah it's cool but
oh that's a good one yeah I wonder
though if there's a bunch of undisclosed
government like enclave of bunkers we
don't know about I bet there are why
wouldn't there be
why wouldn't there be yeah because they
have directed 51 right that's what he's
trying to pay for he's like how are we
gonna
for our underground bunkers if we who's
gonna who's going to serve us Noble
elites I just signed the check it needs
to clear who's going to rebuild the
ivory tower after it collapses in
nuclear war that's a very fair question
the slaves the peasants so here let's
let's real bit more so well I'm sorry
about critics critics field the whole
underlying concept of surviving
disasters through an individualized
bunker mentality is fundamentally flawed
the fortified condo is just not viable
it's not a viable doomsday strategy said
Douglas rushkoff author and host of the
team human podcast it's a Western
billionaires view of the world totally I
agree
like real true yeah you need a community
you need you need like a group of people
know how to do different things
oh really is this like yeah rushkoff
argues that our survival both as
individuals and as a species relies on
our ability to come together as a
community boom and work to go together
towards the common good exactly I don't
think there are any justifiably positive
reasons for people to do this sort of
isolation as doomsday planning as an
investment right said rushkoff hopefully
as they proceed through this terror
theater they will come out the other
side and realize the only real solution
is to all be in this together bring
human in as it being human is a team
sport yeah that's the thing like how did
humans survive as long as we have oh
it's because we banded together and
taught each other and and you know down
the generations we continued the
information and grew the information and
learned more and more at together as a
group so if we start isolating ourselves
yeah even if it does hit and you know
it's the apocalypse and we're all
isolated in our little bunkers fallout
everyone's just gonna die in different
times in different bunkers yeah that's
exactly so what we actually need to do
is instead of building individualized
multi-millionaire bunkers we need
community ones we need but that's like a
matrix you know but that like I mean
that's at the core of the earth or
whatever but you know they were all it
was a community right but think about
this way in Fallout if you've played
fallout 4 you hear the sirens you run to
the vault and they're like not you not
you you and people are outside screaming
yeah and they're like so you can't come
in yeah and then you know aside from the
fact that fallout they do experiments
the people in the vaults like let's true
decide yeah could you imagine if instead
of this are the US government invested
in community bunkers for emergency
survival and then when the time came you
go and they're like you're on the list
mr. Kriegler come on in
yeah and then you're like but what about
you know my friend what about nope
but he's Tim Poole no and I'm like girl
and you're like my every-man-for-himself
brother welcome to America no regrets no
regrets no but I mean I do think it's a
good point and it's kind of how its kind
of how he ends the article so I guess we
can you know wrap up there try and grab
the last few super chats by um I think
it's it's oh we got five minutes we got
our yeah we got it we got to get to so
we will wrap this one up here uh you
look if you're gonna be in a bunker at
least you won't die right you'll live
for a little longer and then you'll come
out five years later and as a society
and everyone's well that's a movie they
come out and it's no that's a real movie
that's with Brendan Fraser yeah that was
they think the world under different
walk ins is dead yeah no we have to go
down yep because a plane lands on the
right house or something and then he
comes out 35 years later and like
everything's normal
yeah yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8:00 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you